-New York is a character
in this show.
-Yes, as it often is.
-As it often is.
You were the first one to think,
"This was a character."
But you put it
in your neighborhood.
It's an East Village show.
-Yes, and I love it.
-And now you're walking around,
you basically now are --
-you are very much the
character you played,
and you're walking
around the set.
-It has become some sort of a
meta-snow-globe nightmare
like I cannot even describe.
-[ Laughs ]
-The other day, I walked out,
and it's like, in my mind,
it's going to be like
Christopher Walken
in Abel Ferrara's
"King of New York."
You know what I mean?
Looking down, coked up,
and what a city, what a city.
[ Laughter ]
And instead it's me
in the East Village.
And I kind of -- I was going to
meet a friend for breakfast,
and I was like, "At Odessa,
across the street
from Tompkins Square Park,"
which was already ironic.
If you've seen the show --
spoiler alert --
the diner's in it.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-And so, there I was.
I had sort of forgotten
my iPhone,
so I was walking around
with, like, an iPad
as though it was a phone,
which is already like --
just doesn't make you look
particularly sane,
if that's the vibe
you're going for.
And I had a big overcoat.
But it was kind of too sunny,
because who knows
what's happening with
the global warming, et cetera.
And you never know what season
it's going to be, do you?
And then I just had a little bit
of ash on my collar.
Don't smoke.
And I stumbled in to Tomkins,
right where I had, like,
shoplifted at Odessa.
And then I sort of --
there were people there,
and I ended up in the booth,
directly -- exactly where Nadia,
the character from the show,
sat waiting for Alan,
the wonderful Charlie Barnett.
And instead, I was waiting
for my friend,
who was not him, thank goodness.
-Yeah.
-And I realized, like,
"Oh, this is really --
I've created
a bit of a nightmare,
where I'm living
within the thing."
And you know, when I get hit by
a taxi, I won't be surprised,
suffice to say.
[ Laughter ]
-One of the things
about your character --
you mentioned
getting hit by a taxi.
That's one of the many ways your
character dies in New York City.
-Thank you.
-You strike me as someone --
do you see danger
everywhere in the city?
-Sure, you know,
and the place...
Danger and yet a relief.
A sort of a white-noise silence
that would follow.
You know...
-Because you got to watch --
Here's a couple
of your body doubles.
-That's Tawny,
my wonderful stand-in.
And this is Becca,
who has, I guess,
soft bones and a rubber body.
[ Laughter ]
It's really --
She is a magical creature.
I don't know.
But, yes.
And for me, it was such a joy to
see this many doppelgangers.
It really speaks to
my sort of brain damage.
-What spoke to me,
watching that New York thing
of just the metal door that
leads to the basement stairs --
-You're a father.
You can't be walking around
willy-nilly.
-And now more than ever,
because people are on
their phones all the time.
I can't believe, every day,
the front page
of "The New York Times" has
another person fell down.
-Maybe it is, and
we're just ignoring it.
We don't pay attention anymore.
-I'm looking at my phone.
I'm not reading
"The New York Times."
-Well, I mean, and definitely,
I think, you know,
the most problematic, and
I've been intensely vocal
in a way that
no one listens to --
is the bicycles, Seth.
The bicycles.
-You're no fan of the bicycles.
-Just listen,
who loves the environment
more than me?
And yet, this bicycle lane is
a nightmare for the city.
Remember jaywalking?
-Yeah.
-Jaywalking was the best.
It was like, "I'm a New Yorker."
[ Laughter ]
Right?
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jaywalking. And littering!
Littering!
No, no, littering is bad.
[ Laughter ]
But jaywalking was, like,
a real New York joy,
because you looked kind of cool.
You looked over your shoulder,
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-You felt like Lou Reed.
And now, instead,
it's like a bicycle zipping by
in all directions.
-And, again, I'm a fan
of bikes, as well.
I don't want to be
negative-bikes.
-No, I love -- like I said
very clearly,
I love the environment.
-Yeah. We're pro-bikes.
My issue is when bikes think
that they don't have to
live by the traffic laws.
-Yeah, but only in New York
are you, like,
"If you're a pedestrian,
I have the right-of-way.
I'm a taxi driver, I'm Mr. Uber,
I'm in charge.
Bicycles gives me
the right-of-way."
That's a New Yorker.
New York spirit.
"I'm always right,
and you're wrong."
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-Right?
-Well, I think everybody,
you know, just assumes
that whatever is one step up
is a monster.
So, if you're a pedestrian,
a bike --
the fact that somebody
is on two wheels,
they might as well be,
like, a Hummer S.U.V.
You're like, "You monster!"
-Survival of the fittest --
this city.
-One of the things that
has already been asked --
and I should note
that if you never made another
episode of "Russian Doll,"
you would be
in a great situation
of having created
this perfectly formed thing.
But people are asking you a lot,
I would assume,
"Are you going to make more?"
-Yes.
-And is it exhausting
that you finally got
this product you made out,
and immediately
people are like, "so?"
-This is what's so helpful
about the experience of Netflix.
And I'm so grateful that I had,
you know, these seven years
we just finished.
You know,
"Orange Is the New Black"
is very heavy.
Very heavy scene.
And -- Yeah, thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks, thanks.
You know, we're very tight.
So, but what I learned
from that show, thankfully, is,
you know, all year --
all year -- everybody
waits for the show to come out.
It's a 13-hour show.
They consume it
in under 30 minutes flat.
[ Light laughter ]
I don't know how they do it.
That's where I learned about
the space-time continuum
that I use so effectively
in "Russian Doll,"
was in the way that these people
break time on Netflix.
And so I'm used to it.
You know what I mean?
This idea of, like,
"I like it. Give me more."
It's a compliment, but it's
important for us to remember,
you know,
like Janis Joplin said,
"We've only got one day, man."
Et cetera.
[ Laughter ]
So take it easy, take it easy.
[ Applause ]
-Well, Natasha, I -- you know,
I texted you
as soon as I watched the show.
And it is such a special show.
-And I wrote,
"New phone. Who dis?"
-You really did write,
-I did. I knew it was you.
No, I didn't.
-[ Laughs ]
I really, like, wore my heart.
I was like, "You've made
this very special thing."
And you wrote,
"Thank you. Who dis?"
[ Laughter ]
-But I feel like
you changed your number.
In that moment, I was like,
"Oh, Seth has a different number
for when he likes stuff.
Gotcha."
-Exactly, yeah.
I'm like, "Ooh,
I better take out
my compliment phone."
[ Laughter ]
But it is -- It is a really --
It is a really special show.
And I know a lot of great people
worked on it.
But the heart of it is
what a special person you are.
And it's just so great to see it
over the course
of a season of television.
-Seth, thank you.
-And thanks for being here.
-It's just always
such a pleasure.
-Thank you.
-Natasha Lyonne, everybody.